>> Jon: HEY, THAT'S OUR SHOW,
ONE QUICK THING BEFORE WE GO.
I MENTIONED TO YOU THAT I WOULD
KEEP YOU UP TO DATE ON ANY
NEW INFORMATION WE HAD ABOUT
THE TRANSITION OF THE
PROGRAM, ALL THOSE OTHER
THINGS.
WE DO HAVE SOME SPECIFIC
INFORMATION.
MY LAST DAILY SHOW PROGRAM
WILL BE AUGUST 6th.
I WILL BE WEARING A SUIT.
I WILL MORE THAN LIKELY BE
SHOWERED, I'M SORRY, I WILL
BE WEARING OVERALLS AND I
WON'T SHOWER.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
SO I HOPE THAT YOU WILL JOIN
US FOR THAT PROGRAM AND AS A
MATTER OF FACT, YOU CAN
ACTUALLY JOIN US HERE IN
REALITY ENTER A CHANCE TO
WIN TICKETS TO MY FINAL
EPISODE OF THE DAILY SHOW IT'S
GOING TO BE A PRETTY GOOD
EPISODE, I THINK.
YOU'D BE FLOWN TO NEW YORK, PUT
UP IN A NICE HOTEL.
YOU MIGHT EVEN SIT HERE.
MAYBE I WILL GIVE YOU A
LITTLE WHAT DO YOU CALL IT
THERE, SELFIES THERE.
AND ALL OF THE MONEY GOES TO
NIGHT OF TOO MANY STAR NEW
YORK COLLABORATES FOR
AUTISM.
GO TO OMAZE.COM/DAILYSHOW
AND THEN MAYBE I WILL SEE YOU
HERE AUGUST 6th AND WE'LL
HAVE A NICE HUG. WE'LL HUG.